[Applause]
yo when you made that record with
mulatto
uh record is dope but uh
i feel like it's awkward for me to
listen to a child speak about the things
you spoke about on that song
obviously you're a father uh but like
wha
what was uh what was the vibe like with
her making that record because it's a
very explicit
record like i said i'm a grown
man hey fema just know about me man
oh girl yeah i would probably i i mean
let me stop me if i'm wrong but i'm
assuming you've probably slept with more
women that are um
over aged that i'm saying yeah what's
the oldest
she was like 40
40 something for this song she ain't
look 40 though
yeah chop that [ __ ] i'm grown 40
something yeah
she knew that i want to say 47
but she will find that's something else
damn you [ __ ] you definitely [ __ ]
someone's mom then
for soap yeah so and did she know you
were
under age
you're a grown-ass man i understand that
but technically she's a child molester
well but not really though because
technically most of the women you [ __ ]
their child molesters
technically not really though cause
guess what if she was if she was 18
right
it would be to sign charge it depends on
what state you're in i think there's a
three-year window in certain states
but 47 that's that's some child
molesting that [ __ ]
look at this the last interview we did
your mom was in the room and she was
like
do you remember that yeah shout out to
your mom man
and shout out to the 47 year old woman
who what
is this uh like she fine bro did you
meet her on instagram or did you meet
her at it's like where did you meet a 47
year old in the airport wow
because i like to say you know i want to
give a little you know
look 47 in an airport
you didn't sleep with her at the airport
did you no no no no
no cause that would have been that i
mean i want to do that though
i'd do that for you at the airport or in
the plane at the airport
in on the planet see the only thing that
sucks about the plane is
the only place unless you you probably
fly private because you're in el chapo
i fly flat i fly in the back of the
plane yeah but you get into that
bathroom and you think this is the only
place i can [ __ ] is this little ass
bathroom
and i just i've i've been in there
taking a [ __ ] on a flight and been like
could i actually have sex in the end
oh god i'd be thinking i ain't gonna
last sometimes on the flight they cut
the lights off no food
oh yeah you could definitely catch a
hand job on the plane
under the blanket all day you know and
no one will notice if it's if it's dark
it's
a you know if it's a nice red eye give a
[ __ ] pink eye on the red eye you feel
me
i just feel like a real piece of [ __ ]
that i'm having a conversation like this
with a goddamn
kid that's not even 18. but you are
you're a father so i'm just going to
give you
we're both fathers so we're binding on i
got a daughter
baby clover it's terrible breaking my
neck